[Music]  it's hard to imagine the panic of people  stuck  in traffic when the road suddenly filled  up with water reinforcements have now  come from all over germany because  not only were residents completely taken  by surprise by the flood  they also completely overwhelmed  government services  we hope that they made it out of their  cars but we are not sure  and we can't guarantee that there are  perhaps people in the cars  [Music]  we have clothes shoes for men women and  children everything they need  it's great to see how much support is  coming in  [Music]  we have nothing left no home no  furniture or clothes  it's so hard but i say to myself at  least i saved my child  as a mother that's the most important  [Music]  it's about solidarity supporting people  to show they aren't alone with this  devastation  when they see all these young people  coming to help them during their summer  holidays  while it's just amazing and heart  [Music]  warming